it's the beginning of August 2019 so
it's time for another monthly update
video in which I'll talk about what
we've got coming up this month and what
you might have missed in July by the way
if you click the read more or see more
button on the video description you'll
see all sorts of links that I think many
people have been missing because they
don't typically click on the see more in
video descriptions now I always like to
begin by highlighting three big things
so no further ado a big thing number one
we've got another video premiere of a
self directed study in philosophy
Sadler's advice video coming up this
month and that will be on Marcus Tullius
Cicero so if you want some ideas about
how to study him you want to tune into
that big thing number two YouTube and
Google have phased out Google hangout so
for our online events we're going to be
using a new interface which YouTube
brought out and which I tested today and
found to be pretty good that is the
YouTube webcam function so you might be
seeing some changes coming up with the
live events big thing number three my
classes not all of them but but most of
them are starting in August so I'm doing
a lot of work getting ready for those
and I've got an idea for videos coming
up having to do with classes that I'll
talk about in the August section all
right so let's talk about July we had
some events face to face events I did a
talk on Gordon Dixon's child series or
also known as the door size series of
novels for the worlds of speculative
fiction the series that was a lot of fun
you can see the link down below I had a
lot of online events my usual AMA a
philosophy popup on the topic of thumos
that I talked about in my presentation
to the Aristotle and Aristotelian
tradition conference back in
here at Marquette did my half-hour
Haegele hangouts we don't feel to call
them hangouts anymore we're gonna to
call him something else and we had our
video premiere her self self directed
study and at the quirian philosophy we
did have to cancel the stoic fellowship
because as it turned out there was a big
event in Shorewood that used the library
the day that we would normally meet it
was a very busy month for me my kids
were still here for the first week of
July so I always like to maximize my
time with them which meant having to do
more work later on I continued to teach
my my ethics class for MATC online began
teaching the business ethics class from
our cat online and shooting a lot of
video content for that I shot over a
hundred videos that are for that class
specifically in and I've got them
uploaded in a different Channel they're
not in the main channel what else
a lot of preparation work as I get ready
for fall where I'm going to have a very
heavy teaching load did quite a bit of
tutorial philosophical counseling and
consulting work editing work as usual
for stoicism today and I was on a
podcast called seize the moment I'll put
a link to that as well below what else I
got to working out once my kids were
left I once my kids had left and I had a
little bit of time to recover from that
so I've been working out three days a
week which is good although you know
often quite sore from that and a little
bit tired in part cuz I'm 48 year old
man video work I I did release some of
the other videos that I had shopped this
summer for my online classes so a lot of
camu work some de Beauvoir stuff some
stuff in a gar some stuff on David Hume
of course I recorded my event videos and
the the video on self-directed study and
epicurean philosophy and I even released
some podcast
my son Matthew did some some work for me
over the summer putting together taking
you know lectures turning them into
podcasts he didn't get as much done as I
would have hoped but you know that's
life and so I've been releasing some of
the stuff on SART didn't get to the
Haegele videos again I was kind of upset
about that but then again I shot over a
hundred videos for the business ethics
class I'm getting close to the end of
that work so you know I'm looking
forward to getting back into that work
the hagel work and some other things
this coming month alright let's talk
about August if you're here in the
Milwaukee area then there are a few
events that you're gonna want to come to
this coming week so starting on August
6th at 6 p.m. at the Frank Weinberg
library and Mequon I'm going to be doing
another talk on the quarterly series
philosophers in the midst of history
this one is on jean-jacques rousseau so
we'll be discussing him romanticism the
French Revolution all sorts of other
things as well on the 8th which is a
Thursday at the Brookfield Public
Library we continue our worlds of
speculative fiction series with somebody
who is a Wisconsin native August Derleth
somebody who also resuscitated
Lovecraft's work you might say from the
pulp grave and and you know published
them again through Arkham House we'll be
talking about his Cthulhu Mythos series
and that should be a fun little
discussion as well on Saturday the 10th
at 12 p.m. we'll have our ama session
I've got about an hour and a half
scheduled for that so make sure you get
there with your questions early I will
answer questions more or less in the
order that they come in although you
know if you're asking questions that
been asked many many times about you
know Peterson or G Jack or Nick land or
stuff like that I'll probably skip your
question so you know make sure you got
something that's kind of on point - same
thing on the 10th 3 p.m. we've got our
our patreon exclusive philosophy chat
this month I'm gonna be opening it up
not just for the it's usually for the
upper tier patrons but I'm gonna be
opening up to all the patrons in part
because it's my birthday coming up this
month not far from that and so that's a
little birthday present of me to my
patrons on the 12th at 5 p.m.
we'll have our public half-hour hagel
Q&A and discussion session that's open
to anybody if you want to join in on the
24th at 12 p.m. we'll have our video
premiere of Cicero and self-directed
study my advice for four people so if
you want to join in be one of the first
people to watch it and also get to
engage in chat with me in real time then
you definitely want to come to that and
then finally on the 24th 2 p.m. patreon
exclusive half-hour Haegele session as
well so I mentioned that I've got a
pretty heavy teaching load going on the
business ethics class that that's online
six-week business ethics class finishes
about halfway through October I'm
designing two other online classes for
Milwaukee Area Technical College one of
them I've been planning for quite a
while and that's with the second chance
Pell program which is a way that
prisoners can actually take classes for
college credit one thing that we know
from studies is that you know college
education really reduces recidivism it's
one of the most cost effective ways to
keep people from going back to prison so
I'm very happy to be participating in
that again I'm also doing an intro to
philosophy class for for MATC they
called me up kind of last minute and
said hey can you fill in for us so I I
said yes even though I've already got
quite a few other classes on the docket
so Marquette same sort of story they
need me and I'm teaching two sections of
foundations of philosophy starting in
August what else
teaching from Milwaukee Institute of Art
and Design again their intro to
humanities class this time for
sophomores who somehow fell through the
cracks and didn't take it their freshman
year and I'm doing an experimental class
called philosophy mindfulness in life
which is not so much about mindfulness
as such that was just stuck there in the
title it's really about philosophies as
ways of life so mindfulness fits into
that rather than philosophy fitting into
mindfulness and then finally I'm
teaching business ethics for Carthage
College down in Kenosha and I went down
there last week and got my ID badge and
parking thing and talked with the
business chair and that's gonna be a fun
class as well so there's a lot of
preparation work that I'm doing ahead of
time because even my face-to-face
classes I always want to have all the
assignments set up and all the readings
and have the whole course thing built
out and that includes providing videos
to my my students I give them the core
concept videos to help them out I'll be
using the the business ethics videos
that I shot and I'm still in the process
of shooting for my business ethics class
in the fall as well as resources
students love having access to that even
if they're going to be there
face-to-face and there's a lot of other
things too you know handouts lesson
pages sets of links all those things are
quite important to have in a good class
what else you know I'm heading down to
see my kids on my birthday which is
August 18th and they're in Indiana so I
get to spend time with them well
probably you know do some hiking play
some board games hang out with my
relatives and then I'll head back up
here to get ready for work again
alright because I've got stuff to do on
Monday video work this is the month
where I'm actually gonna get some
Haegele videos done I've got some time
blocked out for it it's quite difficult
to do these half-hour Haegele videos
while I'm doing other work but it's it's
important that I get back to it I'm
going to be shooting a lot of core
concept videos I don't know that all
lise all of them this month but I'm
shooting the following content for my
students
Plato stuff Aristotle stuff Seneca stuff
Cicero stuff Augustine Boethius and some
and Aquinas so lots and lots of stuff
for the first part of the semester for
my intro classes for my foundations
classes and I can't even use some of it
believe it or not in the business ethics
classes and in the experimental class
I'm going to shoot some book review
videos this month if I don't get too
bogged down and I've got an idea that
maybe some people would be interested in
me shooting videos specifically talking
about the courses that I'm teaching and
you know what I'm having the students
read and and what sort of assignments
we're doing and what kind of activities
and what sort of resources I'm providing
them and and you know my general take on
the class so I think I'll shoot some of
that stuff as well if I get to it I may
shoot some Sadler soapbox videos we'll
see about that
podcasting stuff I'll be releasing
another sartre podcast lecture and then
some Aristotle stuff from the
metaphysics that Matthew did get to
editing for me you still left me some to
do and then we'll see where we go from
there so that is what is coming up in
August as we gear up towards classes and
a very busy busy fall hopefully I'm
going to continue working out three
maybe four times a week and yeah maybe
I'll see you in some of these online
events
you